en estos vídeos nos vamos a embarcar en
una aventura para obtener una fórmula
que luego es muy fácil de aplicar en los
cursos de estadística pasa como en los
vídeos de cocina nada más te muestran el
resultado final así de la nada aquí
vamos a ver cómo sacarla sin embargo te
advierto que vamos a usar matemáticas
espeluznantes porque pues va a haber
muchas cuentas casi todas de ellas
algebraicas al final se pone un poquito
más padre pues vamos a usar parciales y
cálculos pero si algo de esto te suena
muy espantoso o crees que te va a
desanimar no tienes que ver todo de
hecho hasta el final de los vídeos
puedes ver el resultado recién sacado
del horno de cualquier forma lo que yo
te recomiendo es deducir la fórmula
conmigo porque es mucho más
satisfactoria todo empieza tomando n
puntos
en el plano xy voy a dibujar aquí un
plano x para poner los n puntos
como puedes ver estoy dibujando nada más
el primer cuadrante pero esto no tiene
por qué ser así de hecho me voy a quedar
en el primer cuadrante nada más por
comodidad ahora supongamos que tenemos
este punto de por aquí no mejor déjame
hacerlo con colores distintos ahora sí
supongamos que tenemos este punto de
aquí y que sus coordenadas son x1
como de uno luego supongamos que tenemos
otro punto no sé pues por acá sabes que
mejor lo hago también con otro color
distinto ok entonces tenemos otro punto
por acá con coordenadas x 2,72 y después
voy a seguir agregando puntos déjame
dibujar algunos más
voy a poner este y este y este de acá y
pues voy a hacer esto hasta llegar al
enésimo punto entonces por acá voy a
dibujar el enésimo punto digamos algo de
este estilo y va a tener coordenadas x n
coma tiene muy bien entonces tenemos n
puntos dibujados en el plano xy aquí ya
dibujé a todos ellos lo que quiero hacer
es encontrar una línea que minimice el
error cuadrática a estos puntos de acá
déjame visualizar esta línea más o menos
entonces va a existir una línea que
ahorita voy a intentar dibujar que en
cierto sentido va a aproximar a los
puntos la voy a dibujar más o menos algo
así si no sabes que un poco más parecida
a los puntos algo de éste
y no quería que pasara por el punto de
allá a ver ahí va un intento más algo de
este estilo muy bien esto va a estar
mejor o sea realmente no sé si se va a
ver así pero lo que quiero hacer es
minimizar el error cuadrática de cada
uno de estos puntos a la línea favorita
te cuento del error cuadrática antes de
eso supongamos que la ecuación de esta
línea es que es igual a mx + b esta
expresión viene directamente de álgebra
1 aquí tenemos la pendiente de la línea
la pendiente y b es la ordenada al
origen de hecho la línea intersecta por
acá en el 0 b 0
va con este planteamiento lo que quiero
hacer en este y los siguientes vídeos es
encontrar una m y una b es decir las dos
variables que definen a la recta de modo
que se minimice el error cuadrática y
aquí te preguntas qué es el error
cuadrática pasemos a eso para cada uno
de los puntos diremos que el error entre
él y la línea es la distancia vertical
entre ellos entonces a esto que voy a
marcar por aquí este de aquí le vamos a
llamar el error 1
el error 1 ahora a este de acá a este
que estoy marcando le vamos a llamar el
error número 2 es su distancia vertical
hacia la línea también lo puedes pensar
en coordenadas como la diferencia de las
coordenadas en g
ahora vamos a seguir haciendo esto hasta
el enésimo punto tomamos la diferencia
de las coordenadas en del punto y del
punto en la línea ahora vamos al error 1
si pensamos un poquito es este valor de
1 es decir el error es igual a 1 menos
el punto correspondiente en la línea y
cómo le hacemos para encontrar este
punto pues a ver aquí tenemos x igual a
x1 y este punto está sobre la línea
entonces sería igual a mx1b verdad
simplemente estamos tomando x1 en esta
ecuación de la línea para obtener el
punto sobre la línea entonces va a ser
igual a mx1 más b muy bien esto de aquí
es el primer error vamos a seguir con
los otros puntos con el segundo punto
vamos a tener de 2
mx2 más ve porque pues o sea este punto
de acá es mx2b porque ahora estamos en
valor x igual a x2
en esta línea ahora vamos a seguir
haciendo esto hasta el enésimo punto
este último error el enésimo va a ser
llene menos m x ahora xe n por equis n
más b
ok ahora lo que queremos hacer es de
cierta forma minimizar el error total
pero no vamos simplemente a sumar todos
los errores lo que queremos hacer es
minimizar la suma de los errores pero al
cuadrado sale entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es sumar todos estos errores pero
elevados al cuadrado déjame apuntarlo
para hacer el álgebra entonces vamos a
definir el error cuadrática de esta
línea como la suma de los cuadrados de
cada uno de estos errores entonces este
primer error el error 1
efe 1 - mx1b y además de eso lo vamos a
elevar al cuadrado ok entonces esto de
aquí es el primer error elevado al
cuadrado vamos al error 2 en rojo es de
2 - y luego hay que poner que dijimos
así hay que poner mx2 + b y eso de ahí
vamos a elevarlo al cuadrado va otra vez
elevamos al cuadrado vamos a seguir
haciendo esto sumamos todo así
sucesivamente hasta el enésimo error
entonces vamos a llegar hasta él
cn - m x n b y ese error una vez más lo
vamos a elevar al cuadrado fantástico
entonces esto de aquí es el error
cuadrática con respecto a la línea lo
que queremos hacer en los siguientes
vídeos es determinar determinar los m&b
que que minimicen esto que minimicen el
error cuadrática con respecto a la línea
esta línea de acá fíjate en que se
convierte en nuestro problema si
consideramos al error cuadrática como
una métrica estamos haciendo una
optimización así de alguna forma
estaremos dando la mejor recta que se
aproxima a los puntos esto lo vamos a
hacer en los siguientes vídeos poco a
poco número uno para no darte tantas
ideas de golpe y número dos ya que
estamos optimizando para minimizar la
probabilidad de que me equivoqué en las
cuentas hasta la próxima